it's time for another challenge charlie
hello today on Charles Charlie I have
been challenged by this person to teach
myself how to do the juggle I ain't
never not done juggling before but I
have some juggling balls I have watched
a few video tutorials and I reckon I'm
prepared to teach myself another point
of the skill because I am an absolute
beginner I am going to start with just
one ball apparently the thing about
juggling is that it takes a long well it
takes a long time to get a hang of and I
obviously need a lot of practice so I'm
going to be shooting this video across a
few days and compiling the whole thing
into a kind of chronicle of me learning
how to juggle I just make you aware of
the fact that you are currently sitting
at home in front of your computer
watching one person throw a ball between
their hands what is your life what is my
life
I'm really not sure how I could justify
this as a good use of my time I mean
where is this skill going to come into
play at the future I don't have any
plans to join a circus Oh probably good
thing too because I can't do this the
fact that I have to talk to a camera
while I'm doing this is probably making
it a little bit harder that's my excuse
anyway get serious now people it's still
only day one and I've thrown another
ball into the mix oh I almost hit you
there still need a lot more practice day
two of the juggler fun if you don't
recognize where I am that's completely
fine because I've told you yet this is
the flat I have in London and this is my
roommate Alex oh there is this is arm I
know try it with the third ball I'm just
going to do two balls to start off with
I thought you hold the third ball buddy
now all right oh you will get to see at
least one three ball cascade I know it
was oh my go
all of the video tutorials over all of
the video tutorials I was watching about
this said don't do it indoors make sure
you do it outside where you won't hear
anything yeah if you break Amy I'll be
really annoyed day number three righty
what do you think of my juggling skills
oh you just dropped it yeah I know I
know what about that this is four days
of work this is three days of work
I missed a day yesterday I'll be honest
there was
one time I did like tens varies but I
kind of seemed to recreate that I swear
it happened another look the balls that
was quite a lot that's the third time
I've always hit the camera I promise I
won't hit you
dr6 in the juggling house charlie is it
the garden look at this pretty good ah
oh I dropped it so my friend Craig also
known as wheezy waiter here on the
youtubes he recently made a video all
about juggling and now here I am making
a video all about juggling I think that
we as a YouTube community are ready for
a juggling craze so if you don't know
how to juggle teach yourself how to
juggle and if you do now jungle
show me your juggling skills it's been
almost a week now for me and I'm
starting to get good he said I think I'm
pretty much at the stage where I can say
yeah I can juggle
look at me I'm juggling that is juggling
I can I can do that not very long but I
can so after eight days of practicing I
think I've gotten to the stage now where
I can say challenge completed I can
juggle okay I can job almost well I
don't think I'm going to get much better
very quickly at least let's just say
that so I'm going to stop the view here
challenge completed I can juggle
gesticulation awkward ending the end
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool
dae-sik